Hace ya algo más de 10 años todos vimos
con estupor estas sobreactuadas imágenes.
El 17 de diciembre de 2011, falleció de un
infarto cardiaco el dictador coreano Kim Jong
II.
Había dirigido con puño de hierro Corea
del Norte durante 17 años, entre 1994 y 2021.
Durante su reinado este país vivió la peor
hambruna de su historia.
Fue la conocida como la Ardua Marcha que dejó
a su paso según las diferentes estimaciones
entre medio millón y tres millones y medio
de muertos por inanición.
(Tras la muerte de Kim Jong-il heredó el
poder su hijo Kim Jong Un, un líder ahora
mundialmente conocido pero cuyo perfil en
aquella época a duras penas se conocía dentro
y fuera de Corea del Norte.
La transición duró desde diciembre del año
2011 hasta el mes de abril del 2012.
Y terminó con un joven de apenas 29 años
asumiendo el control total del Partido del
Trabajo de Corea y también del Ejército.
Como los de su padre, los poderes de Kim Jong-Un
pasaron a ser absolutos.)
Desde entonces ha pasado ya más de una década.
Una década durante la cual el “reino ermitaño
de ideología Juche  ha estado
bajo el control total de Kim Jong-Un y no
ha dejado de copar regularmente los titulares
de los principales medios internacionales.
Estoy seguro de que la mayoría de vosotros
conocéis ya muchos de los grandes acontecimientos
que han rodeado a este hermético país durante
estos diez años.
Sin ir más lejos podemos destacar su conversión
en toda una potencia nuclear.
Ahora bien, realmente, ¿cómo ha cambiado
Corea del Norte durante este tiempo?
¿Cómo ha logrado el joven Kim consolidar
su liderazgo en un régimen dominado por viejas
glorias?
¿Qué se esconde tras las principales decisiones
adoptadas por el líder?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿hacia dónde se dirige Corea del Norte?
Pues bien, estas y más preguntas os las vamos
a responder en este vídeo.
Así que…
¡Arranquemos!
[Pero antes, una pregunta, ¿sabías que cada
año las empresas se gastan más de 1 billón
de dólares en recomprar sus propias acciones?
En los últimos años esta se ha convertido
en una de las prácticas más habituales de
Wall Street y el resto de mercados financieros.
Las empresas se gastan cantidades desorbitadas
de dinero en adulterar la demanda de sus propias
acciones.
Esto ha hecho que, por ejemplo, la Administración
Biden le haya pedido al Congreso que castigue
estas operaciones.
Ahora bien: ¿En qué consiste esta práctica?
¿Por qué se ha puesto tan de moda?
¿Qué problemas y qué ventajas conlleva?
Para conocer una de las grandes tendencias
de Wall Street no te pierdas el último vídeo
Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
Dicho esto, continuemos]
Queridos amigos, amigas, podemos dividir la
década que Kim Jong-Un ha estado al frente
de Corea del NOrte en cuatro grandes etapas:
La primera, entre 2012 y 2013, fue la fase
de consolidación de su poder.
La segunda, entre 2013 y 2017 la podríamos
denominar como la fase Byungjin (PRON: Byong-tsin),
luego os hablaremos de ello.
La tercera entre 2018 y 2019 fue la fase de
la diplomacia.
Y la cuarta desde 2019 hasta nuestros días
bien la podríamos conocer como la Fase Covid.
Pues bien, las dos primeras fases supusieron
un impulso, un cambio clave en la política
norcoreana: el fin de la conocida como doctrina
Songun.
(Songun fue la doctrina norcoreana que imperó
en todas las políticas del dictador Kim Jon
Il.
Esta doctrina se basaba en la idea del “ejército
primero” y conforme a ella las fuerzas armadas
norcoreanas eran siempre prioritarias.
Es decir el uso de los recursos disponibles
debía dirigirse siempre en primer lugar al
desarrollo de las capacidades militares del
país.
El resultado fue el impulso definitivo del
programa nuclear y balístico.
En 2013, sin embargo, Kim Jon-Un decidió
que esta política tenía que flexibilizarse
y que a partir de ese momento el desarrollo
del ejército tendría que ir siempre acompañado
del desarrollo civil.
Y así fue como nació la doctrina Byungjin
que, literalmente, significa
“desarrollo paralelo”.
Conforme a esta nueva política los recursos
del país ya no sólo se destinarían a las
fuerzas armadas, sino también a mejorar las
condiciones de vida de los norcoreanos.
Al menos, de los más fieles al régimen.)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué Kim Jong-Un decidió
llevar a cabo un cambio tan importante apenas
un año después de hacerse con el poder total
y absoluto?
Pues, básicamente, lo hizo porque la economía
estaba destrozada tras el mandato de Kim Jong
Il.
Tras la terrible hambruna, el esfuerzo realizado
en desarrollar armas de destrucción masiva
y el declive de sus viejas e ineficientes
industrias, el país ya no daba más de sí.
Así que el actual líder apostó por este
cambio con el objetivo de que la mejora en
las condiciones generales de vida le ayudaran
a consolidar su poder.
Y la pregunta es, ¿funcionó?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que sí…
Aunque no por mucho tiempo.
Atentos.
T1 (LOS FELICES AÑOS DEL NUEVO KIM)
Cuando Kim Jong-Un llegó al poder, su juventud
y su inexperiencia en los círculos de poder
norcoreanos le hicieron temer que se produjera
un golpe interno para arrebatarle el mando.
Y desde luego esa era una posibilidad que
muchos analistas plantearon seriamente.
Al fin y al cabo, pensadlo bien, Kim no era
un norcoreano al uso, sino un tipo que estudió
en Suiza y que era todo un fan de la NBA.
Este golpe podría venir de dos frentes: del
ejército, por parte de algunas de las viejas
glorias más tradicionalistas del régimen;
o del partido, de la mano de algún líder
que quisiera reformar el sistema, tal y como
en cierto modo sucedió en China con Deng
Xiaoping.
Pues bien, os hago una pregunta: ¿qué suelen
hacer los dictadores cuando se toman muy en
serio la posibilidad de que se produzca un
golpe de estado para echarlos del poder?
3, 2, 1….
¡Exacto!
Implantar un régimen del terror, actuar con
rapidez y llevar a cabo un montón de purgas
lo antes posible.
Vamos, de primero de tirano.
¿Pues sabéis qué?
Eso es exactamente lo que hizo el líder norcoreano.
El joven dictador quiso demostrar que no por
ser jóven era débil.
Y desde luego si algo ha quedado claro con
el paso de los años es que al tipo no le
tiembla la mano.
Seguro que todos recordáis el asesinato de
su propio hermano, Kim Jong Nam, en febrero
de 2017 en el aeropouerto de Kuala Lumpur,
cuando dos mujeres se le acercaron por detrás
y le envenenaron.
(Anteriormente, a finales del 2013, Kim Jong-un
ordenó una ejecución mucho más importante
a efectos políticos, la de su tío Jang Song
Thaek (PRON: Tsang Song Tek).
Un alto cargo del régimen que fue fusilado
tras ser acusado de faccionalismo, corrupción,
drogas y juego.
Esta fue una de las purgas de más alto nivel
desde los años 50.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Y por qué lo mató?
Pues lo cierto es que se sospecha que este
alto cargo era contrario a las nuevas políticas
que quería implantar Kim Jong-Un.)
Además, en este caso, el joven dictador se
encargó de que absolutamente todo el país
y todo el mundo se enterase de este cambio
de juego.
Fue algo así como un aviso a navegantes:
¿débil?
¿quién dice que soy débil?
mira, por tu bien no te la juegues llevándome
la contraria o serás el siguiente.
(Kim Jong-un de Corea del Norte purga a su
tío de forma espectacularmente pública - The
Guardian)
Y el caso es que este tipo de purgas tuvieron
su efecto.
Desde entonces el liderazgo de Kim no se ha
vuelto a poner en cuestión - al menos que
se sepa - y gracias a eso pudo implantar la
nueva política que el nuevo líder quería
convertir en su máximo estandarte: la doctrina
Byungjin.
(Bajo la nueva política Byungjin,
o de desarrollo paralelo, Kim le prometió
a su pueblo que nunca más tendrían que apretarse
el cinturón.
Con este nuevo modelo, Kim quería impulsar
una reforma económica al estilo chino, es
decir, sin apertura política.
Por ejemplo, reconoció los mercados privados
y promulgó una Ley que le daba más autonomía
a las empresas públicas.
La idea era favorecer un cierto grado de emprendimiento,
eficiencia productiva y competencia sin propiedad
privada.
Y eso no es todo, también creó alrededor
de 20 zonas de desarrollo económico y una
Ley de Joint Ventures con la que intentar
atraer capital extranjero, sobre todo capital
chino)
Por supuesto hablamos de un país dónde la
planificación estatal es practicamente omnipresente.
Así que estas zonas económicas especiales
se dividieron en zonas agrícolas, industriales
o turísticas entre otras especialidades.
Ahora bien, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es: ¿sirvieron todas estas reformas para
mejorar la situación económica del país?
Pues lo cierto es que parece que sí.
Las primeras reformas bajo el liderazgo de
Kim Jong-Un mejoraron las condiciones económicas
del país, e, incluso, se estima que en 2016
su economía tuvo el mejor año desde 1989,
justo antes del colapso de la Unión Soviética.
Tampoco es que fuera para lanzar cohetes
Hablamos de un crecimiento económico estimado
de aproximadamente el 3,9% según cálculos
del Banco Central de Corea del Sur.
Cálculos que se realizan a partir de informes
de inteligencia, análisis satelitales y la
evolución de las exportaciones y las importaciones,
entre otras parámetros.
Sea como fuera, la cuestión es que se empezaron
más coches en las calles, niveles de consumo
algo mayores en las grandes ciudades y un
cierto auge en el sector de la construcción.
De hecho, aquí en VisualPolitik, tenemos
un vídeo en el que os hablamos de los grandes
proyectos de Corea del Norte.
Os dejo el link en la descripción.
Y a ver, no se trata de que el país fuera
como un tiro, ni mucho menos, pero para los
estándares norcoreanos pues…
Las cosas sí que empezaron a mejorar.
Y, amigos, amigas, los cambios no se limitaron
al ámbito económico…
En el campo político también hubo novedades.
Fijaos.
(El joven Kim reformó la estructura de poder
dentro del Estado para que el Ejército ya
no fuera la institución más poderosa del
país, sino que esta pasara a ser el Partido.
Es decir, bajo el mando de Kim Jong Un los
cargos civiles se han impuesto a los militares.)
Eso sí, hablamos de Corea del Norte, uno
de los países más militarizados del mundo,
así que pese a todo el líder juche aprovechó
la
relativa “bonanza económica” para terminar
de desarrollar el programa de armas nucleares
y balísticas.
De hecho, Corea del Norte llevó a cabo dos
pruebas nucleares en 2016 y 2017, incluyendo
supuestamente la bomba de hidrógeno.
Y también se llevaron a cabo numerosas pruebas
con misiles balísticos intercontinentales,
algunos de los cuales llegaron incluso a sobrevolar
Japón.
(Agosto de 2017: “Misil en tránsito”:
Japón se despierta con una amenazante advertencia
sobre un lanzamiento de Corea del Norte
Las sirenas sonaron, los trenes se detuvieron
y los residentes se pusieron a cubierto cuando
un misil disparado por Corea del Norte voló
sobre territorio japonés durante dos minutos.)
Obviamente esto ya fueron palabras mayores.
Misiles norcoreanos sobrevolando Japón y
haciendo saltar las alarmas antimisiles en
uno de los principales aliados de Occidente…
La respuesta, estaba claro, no iba a hacerse
esperar.
Y sí, fueron estas pruebas, tanto las nucleares
como las balísticas las que dieron un portazo
al espejismo de progreso y apertura que parecían
haber puesto en marcha las reformas de Kim
Jong Un.
(Septiembre de 2017: El Consejo de Seguridad
impone nuevas sanciones a la República Popular
Democrática de Corea, incluida la prohibición
de venta de gas natural y la autorización
de trabajo para sus ciudadanos - UN Press)
En ese momento la comunidad internacional
le impuso al país las sanciones más duras
que ha sufrido hasta la fecha, incluyendo
la prohibición de venderles gas y severas
limitaciones a las ventas de petróleo.
Además, también se prohibió la concesión
de permisos de trabajo a los norcoreanos,
de tal forma que muchas de las empresas públicas
que operaban en el extranjero para conseguir
divisas tuvieron que cerrar.
Lo que por supuesto acabó con una importante
vía de financiación para el régimen.
Como os podéis imaginar esto lo cambió todo.
La buena racha llegó a su fin y la economía
norcoreana volvió a entrar en una dura recesión.
En apenas 2 años se estima que el comercio
internacional de Corea del Norte se hundió
un 57%, pasando de unos 6.500 millones de
dólares al entorno de los 2.800.
Y desde entonces no ha levantado cabeza.
De esta forma el plan de Kim se fue directamente
a la papelera.
Sí, había cambiado la doctrina dominante,
pero lo que no cambió fueron las prioridades:
la supervivencia del régimen por encima de
todo, incluyendo, por supuesto, las esperanzas
de un mejor nivel de vida de la población
norcoreana.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿Qué hizo Kim
después de semejante fracaso?
¿Qué se le ocurrió a este decrépito régimen
para salir del pozo?
Pues prestad mucha atención porque estoy
seguro de que ahora muchos vais a entender
la historia completa de lo que pasa con Corea
del Norte.
T2 (LA FALSA DIPLOMACIA)
En 2017 se alinearon los astros para Kim Jong-Un.
Por un lado estaba Donald Trump como presidente
de los Estados Unidos, un líder nada común,
con un fuerte carácter populista y encantado
de sentarse a charlar con cualquier tirano,
incluso con el líder de la peor dictadura
de la Tierra.
Por otro lado, acababa de llegar al poder
el ahora ex-presidente surcoreano Moon Jae
In , un discípulo de la
Sunshine Policy, la política de apertura
hacia Corea del Norte de finales de los 90.
¿Qué mejor oportunidad para Kim Jong-Un
que aprovechar semejante panorama y presentarse
como un tipo dispuesto a negociar con una
aparente voluntad de llegar a un acuerdo,
incluso aunque esto supusiera la desnuclearización
de Corea?
[Un viejo truco norcoreano, por cierto]
Pero es que la cosa iba todavía más allá…
A fin de cuentas, ¿qué líder democrático
no querría vender un éxito político tan
grande como conseguir un tratado de paz definitivo
para la guerra de Corea o la desnuclearización
de la península coreana?
El caramelito era muy dulce para todas las
partes.
(El régimen norcoreana se dio cuenta de que
las sanciones de la ONU estaban causando más
estragos de lo que habían calculado.
Así que necesitaban que estas se aliviaran
fuera como fuese.
Y la única forma de conseguirlo era mejorando
sus relaciones con Washington.
Lo que pasaba sí o sí por detener todas
las pruebas y las constantes provocaciones
militares.
Era el tiempo de la diplomacia, de la diplomacia
del farsante.)
Un tipo de diplomacia ésta, consistente en
ofrecer algo que realmente sabían que no
iban a cumplir para lograr lo que el régimen
necesitaba.
¿Recordáis eso que dijo Kim de que los norcoreanos
no tendrían que volver a apretarse el cinturón?
Pues… justamente eso.
De esta forma entre los años 2018 y 2019
presenciamos dos imágenes históricas.
Por un lado, un presidente de Corea del Sur
regresaba a Pyongyang después de 11 años
y por otro un dictador norcoreano se reunía
en dos ocasiones mano a mano con el mismísimo
presidente de Estados Unidos, algo que nunca
antes había ocurrido.
Unas imágenes tan raras como extrañas.
Unas reuniones que, por supuesto, no tardaron
mucho en saltar por los aires.
(El último acercamiento entre Corea del Norte,
Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur tuvo lugar
en 2019 en la ciudad vitenamita de Hanoi.
Esta cumbre fue un auténtico fiasco.
Después de casi dos años de paripé, Kim
todavía no había logrado su auténtica meta:
que se levantaran las sanciones contra Corea
del Norte.
Y claro, el paripé sin ningún resultado
se estaba ya alargando tanto que empezaba
a dañar al propio Kim.
El líder norcoreano estaba mostrando una
infrecuente imagen de debilidad de cara a
su propio régimen:
Digamos que le había dado la mano a su archienemigo
para no conseguir absolutamente nada.)
Así que, bueno, digamos que la cumbre de
Hanoi terminó prematuramente y, según Estados
Unidos, estos fueron los motivos.
("Todo iba acerca de las sanciones.
[...] Básicamente, querían que se levantaran
las sanciones en su totalidad, y nosotros
no podíamos hacer eso".
- Presidente Donald Trump)
(“El dilema al que nos enfrentamos es que
los norcoreanos en este momento no están
dispuestos a congelar por completo sus programas
de armas de destrucción masiva.
[...] Así que dar alivios de sanciones por
valor de muchos, muchos miles de millones
de dólares nos pondría, en efecto, en una
posición de subsidio del desarrollo constante
de armas de destrucción masiva en Corea del
Norte".
- Alto funcionario del Departamento de Estado
de EE.UU.)
Ay, Kim, Kim, te vieron la jugada.
Fue la pescadilla que se muerde la cola.
Corea exigía el fin de las sanciones antes
de hacer cualquier gesto; y Estados Unidos
exigía que Corea del Norte desmantelara su
programa nuclear y balístico antes de levantar
nada.
Era evidente que cualquier acuerdo era imposible.
Así que todo saltó por los aires…
Y la crisis económica de Corea del Norte
continuó.
Hemos llegado ya hasta el 2019…
Y esto fue lo que ocurrió después.
Atentos.
T3 (LA ESTACADA COVID EN EL PAÍS MÁS HERMÉTICO
DEL MUNDO)
El 2019 también fue un mal año para el régimen
de Kim Jong-Un.
Primero, las sanciones seguían en pie y estaba
claro que no iban a desaparecer.
Así que el líder norcoreano ya no tenía
ningún incentivo para seguir mostrando una
cara amable, ¿para qué?
Así que, ¿sabéis lo que hizoo
Pues sí, regresar a la política de refuerzo
a toda costa de las fuerzas armadas, especialmente
en lo que respecta al armamento estratégico.
Lo hizo quizás para volver a mostrarse como
un tipo duro y fuerte ante los propios altos
cargos del régimen o quizás para resarcirse
de su fracaso político, o quizás para recordarle
al mundo que Kim Jon-Un no era ningún tipo
afable y bonachón.
Sea como fuere, esto supuso el fin de la doctrina
Byungjin (PRON: Byong-tsin) y el regreso a
las viejas políticas de siempre.
(Kim restableció en gran medida el sistema
económico de siempre y volvió a hablar en
sus discursos de la importancia de la “autosuficiencia”,
lo que básicamente supone el regreso a la
autarquía dura y estricta que tanto ha caracterizado
a Corea del Norte.
Y en lo que respecta a la política exterior,
Kim Jong-Un fue progresivamente congelando
todos los diálogos que se habían abierto
en la etapa anterior.
Su máxima expresión fue volar por los aíres
la oficina de enlace intercoreana de Kaesong
en junio de 2020.)
Y por supuesto no olvidéis que a finales
del 2019 - comienzos del 2020 fue cuando se
puso en marcha la pandemia del Sars-Coronavirus-2.
Una pandemia que, como todos sabéis, se originó
en China y que provocó que prácticamente
desde el minuto uno el régimen volviera a
cerrarse a cal y canto, no permitiendo ni
siquiera el comercio con China, excepto el
de bienes esenciales.
Así que la economía norcoreana, otra vez,
volvió a entrar en recesión.
Y, dadas las circunstancias, en este país
lo que se pierde no se recupera.
Con la Covid-19 Corea del Norte ha vuelto
a un estado de aislamiento prácticamente
total, a un estado de autarquía absoluta
y de crisis extrema.
Algo muy parecido o, incluso, peor a lo que
se encontró Kim Jong-Un cuando ascendió
al trono en 2011.
Además, la falta de infraestructuras hídricas
y las fuertes lluvias han provocado inundaciones
descontroladas en unas épocas del año, y
sequías extremas en otras, lo que está provocando
de nuevo una crisis alimentaria cuya magnitud
real se desconoce.
(Julio de 2022: Pueblos norcoreanos a lo largo
de la frontera con China se han inundado esta
semana tras las fuertes lluvias, amenazando
con agravar la ya crítica situación alimentaria
y económica en el país.
- Reuters)
(Julio de 2022: La grave escasez de alimentos
en Corea del Norte podría agudizarse
Con el comercio transfronterizo aún fuertemente
restringido por la COVID-19, la ayuda del
extranjero será limitada.
- The Economist)
Entonces, ¿podríamos hablar de una década
perdida en Corea del Norte?
Pues no…
Lo cierto es que no.
Por un lado, Kim Jong Un ha logrado su objetivo
de apuntalar su poder y dar continuidad a
la dinastía Kim, lo cual pese a todo no parecía
una tarea sencilla.
Por otra parte, los años de relativa bonanza
económica han dejado importantes desarrollos
urbanísticos en Pyongyang, Samjiyon o Wonsan,
que han aportado vivienda nueva a miles de
norcoreanos, así como hoteles, hospitales
y mejoras en varios aeropuertos, entre otras
cosas.
Pero la situación que se ha generado en los
últimos dos años podría incluso poner el
liderazgo de Kim Jong Un en riesgo.
Y en cualquier caso, lo que parece claro es
que el futuro próximo de Corea del Norte
pasa por la falta de cualquier nivel de prosperidad.
Kim tendrá un largo 2023 para decidir qué
rumbo quiere para Corea del Norte en la era
post-COVID: un regreso a la política de desarrollo
paralelo, o una continuación de la autarquía
militarista radical de la doctrina Songun.
Como no puede ser de otra forma, en VisualPolitik
seguiremos muy pendientes de todos los acontecimientos
que sucedan en el reino ermitaño.
Pero ahora, llegados a este punto, es turno
para ti.
¿Crees que el liderazgo de Kim Jong Un está
garantizado hasta que el dictador fallezca?
¿Qué camino crees que tomará Corea del
Norte en la era post-COVID?
¿Crees que existe alguna posibilidad de rebelión
interna contra Kim por culpa de la crisis,
bien de las élites del régimen o del pueblo?
Pues bien, déjanos tus impresiones aquí
abajo, en los comentarios.
Y, si te ha gustado este vídeo, no olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a nuestro canal,
dándole también a la campanita para no perderte
ninguna novedad.
Y recuerda, si te gusta lo que hacemos y quieres
ayudarnos a crecer y mejorar, puedes apoyarnos
activamente uniéndote a la comunidad VisualPolitik
en Patreon.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.